in this video I want to talk a little
bit about prokaryotic transcription and
the way transcription is regulated in
prokaryotes so is gene expression
controlled at the transcriptional level
if so how well the answer of course is
yes and how is what we're getting at in
this video so when it comes to gene
expression in prokaryotes the gene
expression is is either regulated or
constitutive now constitute of the
definition is pretty simple essentially
what is going on in constitutive gene
expression is that transcription of that
particular gene is on always that's what
constitutive means transcription of that
particular gene will always be on
regardless of changes in the cells
environment now this is just sort of a
general idea that if a gene is a
constitutive gene that means it will
always be transcribed it won't be
regulated in any way but if a gene is
regulated transcription could be on or
off and it can depend on something now
what does it depend on it depends on
changes in the cell's environment so
when we think about regulated genes
there are generally speaking two sub
categories there are inducible systems
and repressible systems now when you
think about inducible I mean you think
about the word induce and what does
induce me and I think induce I think to
make something happen or to turn
something on so in inducible systems
transcription is normally off but it can
be induced right it can be turned on
that's what inducible systems are like
so in the case of inducible systems
transcription will normally be off and
it can be turned on an example of an
inducible system is something I'll talk
about the lac operon in bacteria there
are also repressible systems now in
repressible systems again what do you
think about when you think repress when
I think repress I think it means to stop
or to turn off
so if it can be stopped or can be turned
off that means it's normally on so a
reversible system that gene
transcription of that gene will normally
be on but it can be turned off that's
its way of being regulated and an
example of a repressible system is the
tryptophan operon or the Terp operon
which we will also talk about in detail
later I hope that video was helpful in a
sort of general overview and
introduction to transcriptional
regulation in prokaryotes I am a tutor
if you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email I move
university gmail comm see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching